GAME
CAM TALBOT LEADING THE NHL WITH
14 V OTHER
WAY.
CHIPPING IT OFE HELMET KNOCKED .
NOP BY JARRETT STURGES
AFTEE FACE-OFF
CIRCLE
ZUCCARELG CARE OF BUSINESS IN
FRONT OF
THEY TRIED TO GET HIS FAFA THEN
RIGHT ON FIALA
AND YODDLETON.
ANGLING IT
1-0, THE WIL MELOCHE
HE'S BACK IN THERE AGAINH GADJOS
BURNS.
HE DIDN'E IRON
BEHIND FIALA
>> Randy: LOOKING AT THE
SEVEN-GAME DROUGHT FOR THE WILD.
THEYY COGLIANO
THEY S TEAM PASS IS A KILLER
HE IS TRYING TO SET UP
ZUCCARELLO
PICK UP BYE TOP LINE
JORDIE OF THE PERIODAGAIN.
GETS IT AWAY
AND HE FIALA
AND THEN ADIN T IT
OUT. CENTER WITH THE KINGS
LEADING DALLAS
>> Randy: KARLSSON SCORES!WN
THERE YOU SEE THE STICK OF
GOOD ENTRYINNER, HIS FIRST GOAL
SINCE POWER
PLAY
SAVED BY
HERTL.
HE DELIVERS THE STRIKE
ANOTHER QUICK SHOTD THEYTHE
OFFENSIVE ZONE AND WORKS HISOR